dr jack zhu is the author of mini web
gpu books in this course he will teach
you the basics of web gpu hi i'm jack
from this video you will learn the
basics of web gpu graphics programming
by building 10 separate web gpu projects
each project will be created on top of
the previous one from simple primitive
to complicated 3d graphics
our end product will be a beautiful 3d
sync service
as shown in here
we will create this web gpu project from
scratch and show you how to add 3d
graphics with gpu acceleration to your
web applications
here i want to thank bo and frequent
camp for publishing this video frequent
time is a great resource for the
programming community and thank you for
all that you do before getting into this
video i like to quickly tell you a
little bit about my background i got my
phd in theoretical physics and i have
over 25 years of programming experience
in c c plus c sharp.net and web
development i have published over 20
books about practical programming on a
variety of topics including graphics
programming machine learning
quantitative finance numerical
computation measures and web
applications recently i created a
youtube channel practical programming
based on my books in this channel i will
present several step-by-step video
series in which i will emphasize the
usefulness or example code to real world
applications
the first video series is about web gpu
graphics program that is based on my
recently published book practical web
gpu graphics the project presented here
are also selected from this book my
channel practical programming with dr su
is new and i plan to update it every
week
i will greatly appreciate if you can
check out my channel and describe it
now let's go to web gpu graphics
programming now let's start a project
one set up development environment the
source code used in this project can be
downloaded from the github link here
this project uses this specific version
so now what is web gpu web gpu is the
next generation graphics api it is a
future web standard for graphics and
compute web gpu will provide the modern
3d graphics and computation capability
with gpu acceleration in this video we
will use the following development tools
to build our web gpu applications first
is with usda code node.js
we will use typescript as our
programming language and we use webpack
as our modular bundler in order to run
web gpu applications currently we have
three options the first one is to use
the chrome ternary to test our web gpu
applications the other option is to run
web gpu applications on regular clouds
through orange trial starting from crown
94 web gpu is available as a origin
trial in the regular clone you need to
register to origin trials and request
talking for your origin the third option
is that groundwater officially support
web gpu in may of this year so after
this me you will be able to run your web
gpo applications on a regular cloud in
this video series i will use the chrome
camera to test our web gpu project here
i suppose you already installed
visual studio code
node.js and also install the tab script
globally on your machine let's start
programming
now let's open a command prompt window
let's make a folder make directory gpu
and a cd into it
and design we are going to run this
command in pm you need what to create a
package.json file
okay this file will restore our
dependency used in this project now we
are going to install web pack and its
command line interface use this command
np
and install ioi
webpack is modular bundler that bundles
relevant the file together to generate a
static asset that can be used by the web
applications here we use webpack mainly
for transparent text grid file but here
we don't use it to bundle other type of
files such as html and image files now
installation is complicated at this
point we are going to start visual
studio code with a comment called period
here is a visual studio code interface
you can see we only have package.json
file but not much happening here now
open a terminal window by pressing ctrl
g key now let's install some dependency
packages first we will install jquery
and the corresponding tab package
npm install jquery
we will use jquery to manipulate the dom
enemies in our applications
next we want to install styling css and
ks
loaders in case if our project contains
starting sheet file we need to use a
style loader and css loader to bundle it
in order to create type script modules
in our project we also need to install
tab script locally npm install
typescript locally
we already install it globally before
opening package.json file you can see
the script section here only contains
the text attribute this is not very
useful here we are going to replace this
section this is the code
here the code allows you to run webpack
in different modes like development
production and a watch mode
now we can see with this file and close
it
now all the installed package are going
to be stored in the node modules folder
here the package.log.json file is
automatically generated for any npm
operations so we don't need to do
anything with it next step is to
initialize typescript file with the
command t as see that you need
this operation create a
configuration file for typescript called
tsconfig here now we open this
configuration file
and we need to replace its content
[Music]
you can see here we settle the target to
the es6 also not we define the root
directory as
isrc and output directory has dist in
the distribution folder now
save this file
and close it
we then created some folder structure
for our project first let's create the
src folder so here we create a folder
called src
we will store all the source file in
this folder next we create a dis default
vrst
which will contain all files that will
be uploaded to the web server for
running our applications in this folder
there is at least the one html file
let's add
index.html file to this folder add
another file index and file
and add some code to
it you can see here we add
the title web gpu project here he one
title check whether your brochure
support web gpu or not
we also have h2 dom elements here and
the set id equal to id gpu check these
adjective elements will be used to
display the text string that will be
returned by a text script function which
will be created later
now we are about to finish the
development environment setup but we
have missed the key step that is we need
to install the web gpu package web gpu
working group i will create a type
definition for web gpu standard this
package matches the work in progress web
gpu api which is
currently is not very stable so it can
change almost the weekly so be careful
to use it anyway let's go ahead to
install it with this command
so here we specify the washing
0.1 and 12 this is the latest version to
install it
they call it web gpu tabs
because web gpu is not backward
compatible so you better use the same
version to run our project otherwise you
need to do some modification to your
code to run applications so i suggest
you use the same version here 0.1.12
after installation we need to configure
it open type script configuration file
you can see here we already configured
we add web gpu tabs and a node in the
tabs
section here you see here we have a node
the tabs so we need to install it use
this command to install this node tab
okay the web gpu is now available for
our project now let's add some
typescript
file to our project first add a new file
called helper.cs file to src folder so
we added a new file
called
harper.ts file
and add some code to it
you can see here we use this
navigator.gpu variable to check the gpu
availability this variable is defined in
the web gpu api so you can see here we
use the fed error
to define the type script function next
we need to create an entry point file
called main.ts file we can save this
file first and close it let's add
another new file to the src folder
called main.ts file
now add some code to this file so we
just import the jquery and also import
the check web gpu function from current
dot cs file let's just implement so here
we define id gpu check to display the
string returned by check web gpu a
function here the id represents h2 dom
element defined in the
index.html file make sure this id is the
same as the id file in that file next we
also need to create a webpack
configuration file now add a new file to
the root directory webpack webpack.js
file
you can see here we define a bundle
output directory as drist and the entry
point is named main here the main src
main.ts5
note that the output file has always
with bundle.ks intention now we can see
with this file and close it
now we can run the following command
from terminal window to bundle our tabs
grid file
in p.m wrong
prod in the production mode
okay finished you can check the boundary
file in the dist folder you can see here
we have several main bundle.ts5 is our
bond file this license file this is
source map file this main main.js file
has been refreshed in the index dot html
file you can see here this
mainbundle.js
this bundle file generated by webpack in
order to test our application we also
need a server here we will use the live
server extension click on the extension
link search for
live server
this is the first one live server here
are already installed otherwise we have
installed link here if you can install
it just click install the building to
install the live server
so i suppose you already install it
now we can open
index.html file right click anywhere
open with live server click this link
this will open our default browser to
display the web page unfortunately
if your default browser is regular clone
it will display the message your current
brochure does not support web gpu
so in order to run webgl application
here we will install cron canary so here
search for chrome can
click it so this night build for
developer just download the cron canary
and install it i already installed this
current energy on my
machine please remember the location
where your current canary is installed
okay i suppose you already installed it
let's go back to a visual secure code we
want to change the default browser to
crown canary which will be easy to test
our web gpu application so press ctrl
shift p and type the preference open
setting here yes so open this file here
you need to add this three line here the
live server setting don't saw
info message well i set it to true this
doesn't matter i also set the root
directory as the dist because our index
dot html file in this directory so this
advanced customer brochure common line
here define the default brochure so you
need to replace this code so you need to
copy your current canary exe file
location and paste it here you must
change it to match your situation now we
can see this file
and close it
now start a crown canary
and type chrome
flags
and search for web gpu
here enable it here i already enable it
so if you not you just need to enable it
to make web achieve available for our
current canary okay we can close it okay
finally we can test our development
environment for web gpu applications
here we have a link on the status bar
area you can see go live link this time
it will start current canary browsers
click this link
you can see create your current browser
supports web gpu congratulations
we have successfully set up the
development environment for web gpu
applications now we completed our first
web gpu project that shows how to set up
development environment
this is a project tool of this
video series here i will explain how to
create a colorful triangle in web gpu as
showing here this is a colorful triangle
this project is based on our first
project you can open project one
directly from visual studio code or
clone the source code from the github
repository gate clone this is a github
link for the project one source i also
put this project to source code into the
github repository here is a link so you
can download the source code used in
this project from this link now we will
open the project project.1 directly from
visual studio code here we first add a
css file called site css to the src
folder src folder either a new file
called
site.css
type some code into this file
then just save and
close it just like a web gl the first
lesson we needed to do to use web gpu
for graphics rendering is to create a
canvas argument from the disk folder
open
index.html file here we need to change
h2 elements from here
here we define canvas element without id
canvas web gpu later we will create web
gpu graphics on these cameras the web
gpu programming consists of two parts
one is a control code written in text
script or javascript and the other part
is a cdl code
run on the gpu here we will use officer
signal language for web gpu called wgsl
which is short for web gpu seeding
language to take advantage of the code
highlight in vs code we will convert the
seed code with wgsl extension into text
script like module to do this we need to
install a cd loader for web pack now
open the new terminal window around the
following command to install the seed
load code in p and install ts fader load
this loader was originally created for
loading gl sl serial code but we will
make it
works for wgsl here next openings
webpack
configuration.js file and add the
following code to it
here the file with wgsl
glsl vs vs means vertex cedar fs fs
means fragment receder so the file with
these tensions will be treated as a
cedar code by this seed loader we design
needed to install a wgio extension from
vs code click this extension link search
for
wgsl here is first one wgsl provider
syntax highlight i already installed
this module so you can see here the code
highlight in this case it is easy to
write cedar code use this youtube so if
you haven't installed it just click
this install button to install it
next we need to add some type
declarations for our seeder add a new
subfolder to the src folder
new folder called tabs then add a new
file called
seed.d.ts file
inside this file we add some content to
this file here we
had declare module
the file with wsl
glsl vs ofs we declare this file as
module so right now we can see this file
and close it now we can write our cd
code in the src folder add a new file
called
seeder.wg excel file then add some code
from this code you can see that
there are two seeders here one is
rotator and another is a fragment cedar
have seen the function for vertex is
called vs main function
vs means rotation function here we have
fs mean fragment seeder main function
the vertex cedar takes vertex data
including word position
color and texture as input the output is
a position in the clip coordinates while
the other outputs such as color and the
texture will be passed to the fragmented
seeder these values will then be
interpolated over the fragments to
produce a smooth color gradient now back
to our example in the vertex cedar we
first define an output structure here
that contains a beard yin position and
the output color we call the we color
inside vs main function we first define
three vertices of our triangle use the
floating point like the two leg so that
we have three vertices
we also specify the colors for each
vertex use a floating point vector3
vector you can see the first one is one
zero zero this means red the second
color is zero one zero is green the
final zero zero one is a blue so we
define different color for each vortex
next we define output using the output
structure here we then convert the 2d
vector of the position into vector 4 the
fourth dimensional vector we put a z
component as 0 and a w component as 1.
similarly we convert 3d vector for the
color into vector four here the one
represents the transparency of the color
in the fragment seeder we take the
output color from the water exit as
input and rotate as the fragment color
okay this is the scale we will use when
creating our colorful triangle in web
gpu so now we can save this file and
close it
next we will use a type script to write
web gpu control code open the main.ts
file
and
replace its contained with the following
new code
here we firstly introduce the check web
gpu function from
kirk.js file then from
cdr.wtxio file we introduce our
procedure from this file we also
imported the site.css
file here we will use it to configure
our web page layout next we create a new
function called create triangle this
function must be an async you can see i
think function because web gpu api
itself is i think inside this function
we first check whether your brochure
supports web gpu or not in web gpu we
can access gpu by calling the request
adapter here once we have this adapter
we can call request device measured that
gpu device this device provides the
contacts to work with the hardware and
an interface to create a gpu object such
as buffer and texture we can also run
commands on this gpu device as with web
gl we need a contacts for our cameras
helmet that will be used to display
graphics here we use the current element
to request web gpu context you can see
here get contact by the name web gpu
this is a keyword used by web gpu to
create the context within config this
context with the device and format next
we define the render pipeline by calling
the create render pipeline methods
inside this pipeline we have several
attributes the first one is a vertex
where we assign the cedar to the module
here with the entry point as we as main
function this function is created in our
cidr file similarly for the fragment
attribute we assign the scenario to the
module and entry point as fs main
function the another required attribute
is a parameter here this attribute
contains a field called topology reset
it to triangle list because we want to
create a triangle in this project next
we create the command encoder and render
path by calling the beginning render
parse this render path accepts a
parameter of type gpu render path
descriptor as a random path option here
we only use color attachments that is an
array to store image information in our
example it stores the background color
in the clear value area
we have another field called the load
value this field will be removed from
web gpu in next version so we don't use
it here next we assign the pipeline to
our
render path and draw our triangle by
calling this drawing measure sphere we
call the ion function to finish curving
the render process meaning that numeral
instructions are sent to the gpu finally
we submit all instructions to the queue
of the gpu device
for execution after running the command
our triangle will be written to the gpu
context and displayed on our canvas
element now we finish the implementation
of our create triangle measures these
measures provide basic procedure to
create web gpu applications that is
firstly initialize web gpu api creator
seeder program
set up render pipeline and appeared
render pass
core draw function submit in tracking to
the gpu for execution finally we call
the create triangle function to generate
our triangle up to now we have finished
our programming for this project we can
now run the following comment
on the terminal window
in npm wrong proud to ban our textbook
code in production mode
okay finished our
bond file created successfully now we
can click go live link from here to
open chrome canary to view our triangle
click this link
here is our colorful triangle you can
see here is red green and blue from a
wine on what has told another you can
see the color changes smoothly because
web gpu interpolated the color
internally which gave a smooth color
gradient now we have a completed project
tool
this is project three we will create a
colorful square using gpu buffer in the
last project we create a colorful
triangle in web gpu by writing a vertex
and a color data directly in the cdl
code this approach is only possible for
creating very simple shapes it is almost
impossible to use this direct approach
for creating complex 3d graphics with
different colors and textures in this
project i will introduce gpu buffer and
show you how to use it to store vertex
and color information in this example we
will create a colorful square to explain
the concept of the gpu buffer here we
will introduce several new concepts that
will be the foundation to create complex
3d graphics objects a gpu buffer in web
gpu represents a block of memory that
can be used to store data for gpu
operations in this project i will show
you how to use the gpu buffer to store
vertex position and color data you can
download the source code used in this
project from this github repository link
you can see we have a specific account
mid-minute version this version is
specific for our current project now
let's start a video studio code and open
project tool that will build in the last
video okay here's the project tool we
used in last video now let's first make
some changes to the
index.html file from drsk folder open
index.html file now we need to change
the hero the h1 title
to create
square using gpu buffer so we don't need
to change the
other part of the code so we can see
this file
next from src folder open higher pro dot
ts file
now we need to add a new function called
innate gpu to this hard profile so we
need to add some code here
you can see we place
our web gpu in this slide is encrypt to
this
function you need gpu so this kind of
roid code duplication because
initialization will be same for our
web gpu projects
this function is the ansync function and
it returns the device canvas of format
and the context which will be used when
we create render pipeline and render
paths we also want to add another
function called create gpu buffer to
this hyper file so we need to add
another function here
called create gpu buffer
you can see
this function takes the three input the
device the data and the usage flag here
we said the default uses flag tool
vertex or copy destination
here you can see we call the device
create buffer a measure to create a gpu
buffer and set the size as the data
the byte lines
to allocate the room for the buffer data
the other attribute here mapped either
creation we said is attributed to true
this means that gpu buffer is owned
by the cpu which is accessible in read
write from typescript code once the gpu
buffer is mapped the application can ask
for access to arrange our content
with get for example here get mapped
range message and set it to the
data to be stored in the platform please
note the map the gpu buffer cannot be
directly used by gpu and it must be
unmapped used by calling the imap
message here or create gpu buffer
message returns imap buffer which
can be used by the gpu
so be careful here about gpu buffers
mapped and unmapped states now we can
see with this file
and close it
next we need to make a changes to the
main.ts file from src folder open the
main.ts file and we need to replace its
content with the new code
you can see here we firstly introduce
you need a gpu and create
gpu buffer from hardpro.ts file and then
we
translater the seed code will be
discussed in a moment
inside the create square message
we first recall the unique gpu method to
create a gpu object and then get the
device
from it
next we define the vertex data and color
data here you can see these are vertex
data and color data here is a vertex
coordinates
of r square a b
c d so the coordinates like here a is
minus
0.5 minus 0.5 which is a b
d we have divided this square into two
triangles a b d d
b
c the vertex of each triangle must be
arranged in the counter clockwise order
you can see here a b d d b c we also
assign a color
to its vertex you can see a is a red b
grain
c blue
and d the yellow you can see here is for
a is red for b is green and so on these
data are consistent with the coordinates
source in this figure of course you can
also divide the two triangle in other
way around for example a b
c
c
d a
so you draw the diagonal this way so you
get another two triangles this dynamic
next we create two buffers by calling
the create gpu buffer one is a word test
buffer and another is a calibre
next we create a pipeline by calling the
create render paper methods the new code
we add here is for the buffer attribute
before we don't have this
the buffer attribute now 80 is a two
element array the first element is for
the vertex position the second is for
the color you can see for the vertex
position we have already stride we set
it to eight since this vertex is
represented use two floating 32 elements
this floating series number requires
four bytes while for the color it is
represented for its vortex using three
floating 32 elements so
it's a restride is set to 12. another
important parameter here is the seed
location for the vertex position we said
see the location to zero and for the
color we set the cedar location to one
the other part of the code is very
similar to that used in the previous
project here we set the promotive
topology to the triangle list one using
here is that after setting the pipeline
to the random path here we also need to
set retex buffer to the random path uses
what text buffer and color buffer you
can see here said what has powerful and
zero slot is vertex buffer and this is
another one we set a color buffer in the
draw function here
we set the number of the vertices to six
because we have two triangles now
now we finish the modification to this
file now we can see
this file next we need to make
modifications to our cd code from icrc
folder open cdr dot wg iso file here
we need to replace its content with a
new code
here you can see we didn't define any
vertices and colors in this cd code
because we store this data in gpu buffer
instead we introduce two
inputs one is at location zero pause and
another color at the location one this
must be consistent with
see the location definition in the paper
in our mean dot cs file because we
define seed location as zero we can
remember for the position and see the
location is one for the color so here
position is zero
and here color is locating one this is
how we set up the relationship between
the vertex cedar and the gpu buffer now
that we define them here as a rectoflow
f32 for the color same thing vert4
f32 it looks like not very consistent
with the data stored in the vertex and a
color buffer where the for the position
is 2d array and for the color is readily
this is because wtsl
seeder is smart enough to automatically
convert them into a vector4 tab by add 0
to z component and 1 for the w component
you can see here we also define two
outputs one is a position y and we color
use a structure inside this obs main
function we process the position and
color data by assigning the pose to the
position and color to the v color inside
the fragment cedar we introduce the wii
color from vertex cedar and rotate as
fragment color okay this is the scene we
will use when creating our square we can
now see
this file
and close it now we can run the
following command in the terminal window
to bond our tab screw the code
npm
wrong broad
to bundle our code in production mode
okay the bond file is created
successfully now we can click
the go live link to open crown canary to
view our sql
so click this go live link
here is our kind of square with
different vertex color here is red
green blue and yellow from wine vertex
to another
you can see the colors changes smoothly
because web gpu interpolates color
internally which gives a smooth color
gradient
okay now we finish the project three
in projects two and 3 i demonstrate how
to create a triangle and a square
graphics in web gpu applications in fact
these two
objects are flat and two dimensional we
have not created any real 3d graphics
yet in this project first i will explain
how to create a 3d cube with distinct
face colors this is the first real 3d
object we are going to create in a web
gpu application you can download the
source code used in this project from
this github repository link here we have
a specific version for this project this
example involves a lot of code and
mathematics so please get ready to
digest it in order to create a real 3d
object in web gpu you need to have the
mass background of 3d matrix and
transformations since our computer
screen is two dimensional it cannot
directly display 3d object to reuse 3d
object on a 2d screen
you have to project your object from 2d
to 3d that will involve a series of
coordinate transformations
from here you can see
that we define 3d object in the object
called in the system here we design
perform various transformations on the
object including scaling translation and
rotation we call this transformation as
a modal transform after this
transformation we convert the object in
the object coordinates into the object
in the word space next the view
transformation locates the viewer in a
word space and transform our 3d object
into camera space that also called eye
coordinates the purpose of the
projection transform here is to define
the vu
volume called your frustum like here
this is a view flash turn this is
usually in two ways it determines how an
object is projected on the screen it
also defines which portions of the
object are clipped out of the final
image that is only the portion inside
this first term will be kept and
anything outside this fractal will be
clipped out
finally we use the view port transform
to convert the clip coordinates into the
normalized
device coordinates in web gpu the
viewport transform here is automatically
performed in the cdl code please note
that like web gl the web gpu api does
not provide any functions for
working with transformation in this
project we will use a javascript package
called gl matrix to create 3d matrix
operation and transformations since the
3d matrix and transformations are common
for any computer graphics programming
here i suppose you already have this
mess background i will not spend any
more time on this instead i will
concentrate on how to create 3d object
in web gpu applications from this
project you will learn some of important
concepts in web gpu that is uniform
buffer and binding group we will use a
uniform buffer to represent the
transformation and projection matrices
and design use the binding group to pass
the uniform buffers to the vertex cedar
now we start with our visual studio code
and open our project 3 that will build
in the last section here is a code we
used in
project 3.
first we need to install a new npm
packages called glo matrix
and pm install gl matrix
and we will use this package to perform
matrix operations and 3d transformations
now let's make some changes to the
index.html file from dist folder open
index.html file here we need to change
the h1 title to queue with this pink
face color so we don't need to change
other parts of the code so we can save
this file
here we are going to create our 3d cube
and these are the coordinates of our
cube
from this diagram you can see there are
eight vertices and six faces if each
face has a different color each vertex
will then have three different colors
for this vertex for example c they have
a top face
front face and right face because this
different face has different color so
the vertex c can have three different
colors depending on which face we talked
about here is the front face a b c d you
can see a b c d here as we did before we
kind now
uh divided this front face into two
triangles one is a b c
c d a this two triangle you can see here
abc and a c d a in this way you can
perform triangular leasing for the other
phases next add a new tab script a file
src folder has a new file
vortex data.ts file i build a new code
to this file
here is the position data for our cube
is front face right facing six faces
this is the color data for the different
faces you can see front face will use
blue color right face is red and back
facing yellow and so on so different
face has a different color all the
position coordinates under the color are
consistent with this diagram showing
here now we can
see this file and close it next we will
make some changes to the seeder code
from src folder opening the
cdr.wtxl file now we need to replace
this content with a new code
you can see this feeder is different
from that we use in project 3 because we
need to incorporate the uniform buffers
that store the transformation and
projection matrices here we define a
uniform structure and then use the
binding group to pass the model view
projection matrix to the seeder here the
mvp matrix means model view projection
matrix you can see here the variable tab
is uniform next we define the output
structure as we did in the last project
is define position and recolor this is
the same as before for the vs me
function we also define the two input y
is the position one is color the same as
the last
project and the inside is function the
only difference is the position not only
has the pulse here but we also
multiply by
this model view projection matrix
so perform the transformation on this
position for the fragment sitter we
still use we color as input and retain
it as a fragment color this is the same
as in the project three now we can save
this file and close it
now we open the hierarchy as file from
src folder
here we first needed to import from gl
matrix we need to introduce the vector
three method four and then add a new
message called create wheel projection
to this file
this method create view projection take
us
four input arguments first aspect ratio
the camera position camera look at
direction and the camera up direction
here we first create a view projection
and view projection matrices a design
use a metaphor perspective and the
metaphor look at
to create a project and a view matrices
next we use a metaphor multiply methods
to combine projection matrix with a view
matrix to form our view projection
matrix this function returns view matrix
projection matrix a view projection and
a camera option the camera option will
be used in the next project when we
discussed the camera control now we need
to add another function called create
transformation this is used to construct
a model matrix
here we first create a three
rotation and matrices for rotation about
x y and z axis we design create a
translation and scaling matrices next we
perform individual transformation for
the input arguments here
finally we combine our transformation
together to form our final transform
matrices which is our modal measures now
save this file
and close it
next we need to make some changes to the
main.ts file from src folder
openmain.ts file here we need to replace
this content with the new code
here we firstly introduce some methods
from
hireport.ts file including
the newly created create transforms
create a view projection we also
instantiate the cube data from the
vertex data.ts file as well as a matrix
for from glo matrix library inside this
create 3d object measures the code is
very similar to that we use in the
project three here we create the vertex
buffer you can see in the color buff
using cube data position and cube data
colors here the pipeline code also
similar to the
project three the difference is here a
re stride for the position is 12 instead
of 8 right now for the cube we have
x y z coordinates so we have 12 here for
our color still 12 because we have rgb
elements here we also set a set location
0 for the position and see the location
is 1 for the color the only difference
in the pipeline here
is we add this tab substantial attribute
here we set depth right enabled to true
to enable the dev substantial testing
the tab substantial testing determines
whether or not a gaming a pixel should
be drawn for 3d graphics enabling text
substantial testing is very important
otherwise you may get high expected
results the following code is new and
specific to our 3d cube here we create a
model of view
and model view projection matrices by
calling the create view projection
measures we then create a uniform buffer
for our mvp matrices you can see here
the usage we said is uniform for our
transformation the size is 64 since our
matrix is a four by four so it has
16 elements each element is a floating
32 number so its size is 64. then define
the binding group by calling create
binding group for this uniform buffer
here we set the layout as a deferred
pipeline get binding group layout zero
this means we use the banning group zero
layout in the entrance attribute we set
the bindings to zero and set buffer here
to the uniform buffer we just defined
here if we have more uniform buffers we
can add the elements here put into this
entrance array in addition to the
texture of you from a context we also
introduce the depth texture
here we set the size as our canvas width
and height and format we use here is
depth 24 plus you can also use other
format the usage here we said render
attachment now our run pass description
including two parts one is a color
attachments and other product is depth
substantial attachment the color
attachment the same as we use in the
project three but the step substantial
attachment is specific for our 3d cube
next we construct the model matrix by
calling create transform
method defined in the
hierarchy as file we then obtain model
view and moep metrics by multiple type
the model matrix for the view projection
metrics so we got the final model view
projection metrics and then we add this
model view projection metrics to our
uniform buffer by calling right above
methods you should
already be familiar with the following
code here we just define rhinoplast and
set vertex and
color buffer but we also need to set the
binding group here use a uniform binding
group which is needed to pass the
uniform buffer to the vertex seeder now
we finish the modification to the
main.ts file we can design save this
file
up to now we have finished all the
programming for this project then we can
run the following command
in the terminal window to bond our
code in production mode npm wrong prod
okay the panel file is created
successfully now we can click the go
live link to open crown canary to view
our 3d queue
click this link
here is our cube with distinct
face color
displayed on this page
okay we have finished this project
this is a project file in which we will
discuss the animation and camera control
in the last project i explained how to
use the uniform buffer to create a 3d
cube in this project i will illustrate
how to animate that cube and how to use
mouse to interact with the code you can
download the source code used in this
project from this github repository link
here the specific command washing is
used for this project for animation we
will use the javascript request
animation frame function this function
can make changes to your screen in an
efficient and optimized manner here is
an example of using request animation
frame you can see here we loop over and
over again using recursion here we first
define the dom element in the ui and
define a start number of zero here next
we create a current function that
increases number by one and design set
it as a text content for the control
element inside this counter function we
call request animation frame and pass
the counter function itself as a
callback function this causes it to run
again just before the next frame finally
we use the request animation frame
function to start the animation this is
the basic usage of the requested
animation frame for using mouse to
interact with the cube we will use the
npm package called 3d view controllers
this package can be used to control
camera with your mouse you can then
interact with 3d object by controlling
the timer now let's start we use the
code and open project flow that will
appear in the last section here is the
code used in projector for first we need
to install javascript package called 3d
view controls open
terminal window and run in pm install
3d
view controls
we will use this package for camera
control
the package is already installed now
let's make some changes to index.html
file from disd folder opening this file
first we need to change ht1 title to
animation and camera control we also
need to add two radio patterns that let
you select whether you want an animation
or camera control here
you can see the video party okay now we
can save this file
theater code in this example is the same
as that used in the project form so we
don't need to make any change to the cd
code now from a src folder open
file
here we need to add a new message called
create animation we need to add a
correct animation here
this is a code for create animation
methods here the draw argument is the
callback function here we want to
animate the rotation around x y and z
axis use the step function here the step
function the create animation has a
boiling argument here is animation
letter controls whether you want to
animate the object or not
now
we can save this file and close it
next we need to make uh some changes to
the main.ts file
openning.ts file
we need to replace the content with the
new code
this code actually is very similar to
the code used in the last project here
in addition to the odd function
introduced from help.ts file we also
introduce create animation a function we
just created now that we use
here required to introduce redeem view
controls module instead of the import
this is because the 3d
view controls package was created using
old modules approach so we have to use
require instead of
import here here we define create camera
from this package in the create 3d
object method we introduce an input
argument is animation and we set its
default value to true here here is
initialization code and a pipeline
called other scene as it was used in the
last project we don't need to make any
change to this code either creating a
uniform data section we define we matrix
this view matrix is the new matrix next
we need to add rotation and a camera
rotating define use a vector3 and a
camera we define create a camera here we
have argument cameras and
camera option we don't need to make any
changes to the code for creating uniform
buffer here and a uniform appending
group this is random parts distribution
also same as that used in the last
project here we put this run pass
related code inside a new function
called the draw function this draw
function
is defined as a callback function for
our animation you can see here if is
animation is not a true we use the
camera to generate our view matrix
and as i multiply projection matrix with
this view matrix to form our
view projection matrix the rest code of
the draw
mixture is the same as that used in the
last project here we start animation by
calling the create animation function
you can see we have a callback function
use the draw function defined here and
finally we need to add a radio button
selection here you can see that if the
radio checked value is equal to
animation we run animation otherwise we
use the camera control now we finish the
modification to the main.cs file so we
can see this file now up to now we have
finished all the programming now we can
run the following comment in the
terminal window
in pm run proud to bound our tabs credit
code
okay the bond file is created
successfully now we can click the go
live link to open cron canary to view
our 3d cube click this go live link
you can see the animated cube on this
page it is rooted continuously because
we
call the animation mode now you can
click on this camera control radio
button here then you can use the left
mouse button to rotate the cube and use
the right button to move
around and you can also use most wheel
to zoom in zoom out the cube so you can
use the mouse to interact with the
cube
so now we have completed this project
in the previous several projects i
explained how to create some 2d and 3d
objects however when rendering this
graphics object with solid colors you
may find that the image looks flat and
has a field to illustrate the 3d nature
of the object this is because we
neglected interaction between light and
surface in our objects lighting helps
provide visual effect to a scene so that
it looks more realistic lighting is one
of the most important factors for
creating real world seated 3d graphics
object however web gpu does not provide
much built-in features on lighting it
just runs two functions vertex and the
fragment considered if you want the
lighting effect in your 3d scene you
have to create the lighting model
yourself in this project i will build a
simple lighting model in web gpu and use
it to simulate the light source here you
can download the source code used in
this project from this github repository
link here the specific commit version is
used for this project here i will
discuss three types of light sources
ambient light diffuse light and a
specular light the amping light is the
light that illuminates all objects
uniformly regardless of their location
or orientation it is a global
illumination in an environment the
diffuse light and specular light and
reflection depends on the angle of the
light to a surface when the light hits
the surface the diffuse reflection
occurs in all directions as shown here
while the specular light reflection
occurs in a single direction as shown
here
here shows the light reflection on the
tour's surface on the left here the
light only from ambient light you can
see this the torus looks very flat here
in the center shows the light
from both i'm being a plus the diffuse
light you can see this 3d feature
already solves here on the right here i
have three light sources i'm being plus
diffused and plus specular lights you
can see this truss looks more realistic
so this is a light model we want to
build in this project
the light reflection depends on the
angle and which the light hits the
surface the angle is essential to the
diffuse light under the specular light
this angle is always associated with the
surface normal that is perpendicular to
the surface to build a light model we
need to calculate the surface normal
based on the direction in which the
surface is facing since the surface of a
3d object can be curved it can face
different directions at a different
vertex so a normal vector is usually
different for different vertex that is
normal vector is always associated with
a particular point on the surface here
shows normal vector for a 3d cube here
the front face is a point
towards the screen so it's normal a
vector is 0 0 y the right face is facing
direction to the right so its normal is
y
0 0 and the top phase is a phase through
the top so its normal vector is
zero
one zero so similarly you can specify
the normal vectors
for the back
left and bottom faces note that the
length of the normal vector should be
always
one that is we need to normalize the
normal vectors for a general
quadrilateral a b c d is a four vertices
may not in the same plane we can divided
it into two triangles a b c and c d a we
can calculate its surface normal in two
steps first we calculate the weighted
number for each triangle which is
weighted by the area of that triangle
the triangle with larger area will get
more weight as we know the area of
triangle is proportional to its cross
products of two sides for example here
for triangle a b c we have a cross
product b c
and c a b c and c a similarly for the
triangle c d a we have cross product d a
and a c the next step is to calculate
the surface normal from the weighted
triangular normals that is the surface
normal equals the sum of two weighted
normal and we can normalize it so we get
this quadrature normal equals normalize
this two cross product the sum this one
triangle plus another one so we can
combine these two terms to form one term
equals cross product c a and d b so this
means the surface number for this
general quadrature just equals the cross
products of
c
a
and d b just equal to the cross product
of these two diagonal vectors we will
use this formula to calculate the light
model for our 3d surfaces
once we have calculated the normal
vector we can use it to compute the
light intensity for diffused light its
intensity is proportional to the cosine
between the light vector here and the
normal vector a you can see here the
cosine of equals normalize l dot a here
if we define the id the diffuse
intensity cut the diffuse material
property so we can have this formula the
diffuse intensity equals kd times
maximum cosine half and 0. here the
maxima is used to avoid the negative
value of the cosine r here we only take
the positive value we can also add the
ambient light to the diffuse light
intensity like this
here i is i am being intensity so the
total light intensity is maxima kd and
clearance ie so we add the ambient
intensity to this diffuse light like
this
for specular light we have two models
one is a form mode this model is very
simple so the rs the intensity of the
spectralite equal to k s has specular
material property and s is the sandiness
of the surface or roughness the v is the
view direction r is reflection direction
one issue with the fun model is that the
angle between the view direction and the
reflection direction has to be less than
90 degrees in order for the specular
phone term to contribute
we can use the blink form model to
address this issue
blink formula uses a different set of
vectors for its computation based on the
half angle vector here's a half angle
vector you can see l the light direction
n is normal vector v is the view
direction h the half angle vector
defined l is light direction plus the
view direction the view direction plus
right direction it gives h here the
formula in opening the model becomes
n dot h
instead of v dot r here so the angle
between this and
an h is always less than 90 degrees so
this entire edge always give positive
value so we will use this plain formula
in our calculation for the regular light
now let's go to the programming part we
start with visual studio code and open
project file that we build in the last
section
and here is a code for our project file
now let's implement the light model in
the cdl code from src folder open the
seeder
seeder.wtsl
we need to replace its content with the
new code
here we first define the uniform
structure here that contains view
projection matrix the model matrix and
the normal matrix
here the normal matrix is the
transformation matrix for the normal
vector data we apply a transform to a
surface we need to derive the normal
vector for the resulting surface from
original normal vectors
in order to transform the known vector
correctly we don't simply multiply them
by the same matrix used to transform our
object but we needed to multiply them by
the transpose of the inverse of that
matrix since the current wg isl version
does not implement the magic inverse
function yet so we have to make these
transfers of the inverse of the
transform matrix in text script code and
design pass it as a uniform matrix as a
showing here normal matrix
we then define a output structure that
contains three variables period yin
position
where we position the position after
some transformation we call the v
position and we normal is a normal
vector of the transformation in our we
as a mean function this contains two
input arguments one is vertex position
called the pose and one is normal vector
data inside this function only perform
modal transform on the position this
gave us v position here because it is
used in the lighter calculation the v
normal is a result of normal vector data
multiplied by the normal transform
matrix here and the default position
here is obtained by perform model view
and projection transfer on the vertex
data for the fragment seeder we first
infuse a uniform structure called frag
uniform that contains two variables one
is the light position or light vector
and the other one is i position or the
view vector also has another structure
called the light uniform here contains
parameters for our
light model he has a light color and a
specular color the specular light can
have its wing color and other parameter
contains ambient intensity diffuse
intensity specular intensity and
specular synonyms
here the fs main function takes a v
position and we normalize its inputs
inside is a function we calculate the
like model here is diffuse just use n
dot l is cosine r for the specular light
we use blinkfern model is n dot h
the output color from fragment cedar
will be weighted you can see by m being
diffused and specular light is a
combination gives the final color so
this is a seeder we are going to use to
calculate the light model now we can
save this file and close it next in the
src folder we will add a new tab script
file called lite.js
and the new file line.ts file
here is the code for this file
here we first create an interface named
light inputs that contains the
parameters used for calculating like
model this code also contains a new
function create a shape with light this
has a four input argument one is a
vertex data
normal data and a light input and there
is animation parameter here we set the
default light parameters if no
parameters were passed so they have some
default value for the lighter parameter
next we create a vertex buffer and a
normal buffer here you can see that the
pipeline contains a buffer attribute
here it is array contains two elements
the first element is a vertex data with
the seed location being zero the second
element is for the normal vector data
with a cedar location being one here the
other part of the pipeline is the same
tool that
we used in project file next we create
uniform data here we define normal
matrix and model matrix and view and
view projection matrix here for
simplicity here we set
the i position we get from the camera
equals i position this means line vector
is equal to the view of vector here we
design create a three uniform buffers
one is a vertex unibomb buffer another
one is a fragment uniform buffer and
finally is a light uniform buffer the
vertex uniform buffer is used to store
the model of metrics view projects
magics and normal matrix the fragment
uniform buffer is used to store the eye
position and a light position and light
uniform buffer is used to store the
light parameter which will be used in
calculating the light model in the
fragment setter
please note here inside this callback
draw function we write model matrix and
the normal matrix inside this draw
function because we want to use the
real-time model matrix to perform
various transformations not only
construct the normal matrix here we
firstly invert this model matrix and
then transpose this normal matrix and
get the final normal matrix that means
we do the inverse and transpose on the
original model matrix and finally get
the normal matrix when we said the data
to the buffer please note here is 64 and
128 is the offset so we also need to use
a correct offset to write this data to
the uniform buffer finally we set the
vertex buffer normal buffer and a
uniform binding group to the render path
now we finished the coding for this file
we can save this file and close it okay
we complete the programming for
calculated light model in next project
we will use the light model implemented
here to create a 3d cube with the
lighting effect
in project 6 i explain how to build a
simple light model in web gpu in this
project i will show you how to use this
light mode to add lighting effect to a
3d cube as shown here you can download
the source code used in this project
from this github repository link this
specific commitment version is used for
this project now start the visual video
code and open our project 6 that will
build in the last section
here is the code used in project 6. as
we discussed in the last section in
order to calculate the light model we
have to know the normal vector at each
vertex on the surface of the 3d object
now we need to add normal vector data to
the vertex data of our queue
from src folder open the
vertexdata.ts file here for the cube
data methods we need to add a normal
vector data here
you can see that red hashes on the same
face has the same normal vector for
example the front face or has zero zero
one similarly for the right is y zero
zero y zero zero or y zero zero and so
on once we add the normal vector data to
this cube data function we needed to
return the long data here's enormous we
also needed to return normals okay now
we can save this file
and close it
next we need to make some changes to the
index.html file from the drst folder
open the
index.html file now we need to replace
this content by the new code
here we add some input parameters here
that let you test our light model
this parameter also allow you specify
object color and i'm being diffused and
specular light coefficients you can also
specify the surface seminars and a
specular color for the specular light
computation now we can save this file
next we need to make some
modifications to the main.ts file from
src folder opening mean dot js file now
replaces content with new code
since most code for render pipeline and
render paths have been already included
in the light dot ts file here the
meanwhile file becomes very simple
firstly you can do create a shape with
light and a light input interface from
the light.ts file and then introduce the
cube data from vertex
data.ts file next we call the queue data
measure to get the vertex data and
define the default parameter clear light
input we just use the default parameter
and also is the animation we set it to
true and then we call the create shape
with light function to create a 3d key
with lighting effect
this part of the code allows the user to
recreate the cube with different
lighting effects by change the input
parameters now we finish the
modification to the mean.tx file we can
now save this file now we can run the
following command in the terminal window
to bond our tax credit code
in production mode in p.m
wrong proud
okay the bond file is created
successfully now we can click the go
live link to opening crown canary to
view our 3d cube with the light effect
click this link
here is a red cue with lighting effect
displayed on this page we can make some
changes to the input parameters and
click the redraw button to recreate the
cube for example we can set the diffuse
and specular coefficient to zero here to
zero and zero and
i'm being
light
to one now click redraw
we get a cube with m being light only
you can see
the cube looks flat and no 3d feature
now let's add a diffuse light and
speculate the bag fuse 0.8.4
for example we can change the color of
the object for example this red we
change it to green 0 1 0 and also change
the specular color from white to yellow
and then click redraw
barley you can see here the yellow you
can increase the sandiness for example
100 you can see the spot a little bit of
yellow is specular light now go back the
animation
so if i change this parameter you can
get new
lighting effect on this cube you can use
this light model to easily create your
wing 3d object by following procedure
presented here
okay now we have completed
project selling the projects we
discussed so far will apply a fixed
color by assign a desired color value to
the fragment color variable in the
fragment seeder in this project i will
explain how to use the color mac to
render 3d surfaces
surfaces play an important role in
various applications
including computer graphics games and 3d
data visualization in some graphics and
chart applications we need a custom
color map to achieve special visual
effects in fact the cloud map is just a
table or list of colors that are
organized in some desired fashion we can
create a custom column map with an m by
three column matrix with its rule
representing rgb values the rule index
can represent the where and data over 2d
chart
all hide our 3d surface plot for giving
column map matrix the current data
values can be linearly scaled to the
color map
here shows the color scripts for the
color maps that we will create in this
project you can see that each color map
has a familiar color map names such as h
i suv hard cool and jazz and so on
you can download the source code used in
this project from this github repository
link this specific commit version is
used for this project
now start with visual studio code and
open our project semi that we just built
in the last
section
here contains the source code used in
the last project now we can easily
create a custom column map using simple
mathematical formula here i will provide
several commonly used karmaps using m by
three
columnability now add a new typescript
file called
columnmapdata.ts file to the src folder
so i access the folder add a new file
called the color map data.ts
file
and then add a new message to this file
here the current data method contains
the 11 different column apps data you
can see hsv
hard and i
has default inside this function you can
see each column map contains 11 rgb
color wrist is i mean right here is rgb
value hair shows the color strip
generated use this column of data this
is right sov corresponding to this
color strip so here is the jet
corresponding this color strip so
these color strips are generated use
this economic data in the current map
data function we assume these 11 color
ray are uniformly distributed in the
range of zero and one for example the
color zero this first
element represents a color at a zero
location while colors file replacing the
color at 0.5 etc however we have to use
the interpolation measure to get a color
at for example 0.55 or any other
arbitrary locations so here we will use
a npm package called interpolate arrays
to do the color interpolation now in the
terminal window
we run the command in npm install
interpolate arrays to install this
package
now at the top of this color map
file we need to introduce this package
here
here you can see again
we use a require to instant use this
package because it was create originally
using the old modules methods so we have
to use the require instead of import to
get this package next we add a new
function here called either colors
here is either colors methods to this
file this function accept the x argument
whose value value is in the range of
minima and maxima this function allows
you to interpolate a color for any
arbitrary x value inside this function
we first get the color array by calling
the color column
data message with the current map name
as input and then make sure the input x
parameter is in the range
minimum and a maximum range next we
normalize x to the range of zero and y
finally we interpolate the color for the
x variable by calling the interval here
the color and the normalized x here this
integral will come from
the interpolate arrays package now this
function returns rgb array with its
component being in the range of zero and
a y so now we can save this file
and close it
next in the src folder rename
light.ts file to the surface.ts file so
we rename this file to surface
this surface.ts file will be used to
create different surface clouds first we
need to make a small changes
to the light input interface here we can
remove the color field here
because we don't need to specify a solid
color for our object but we will use the
color map for the object color then we
add another a new
field called is two side lighting since
the 3d
surfaces are usually open surfaces we
need to implement the light mode for
both the front and the back sides in
order to see the surface clearly but
this parameter controls whether you want
a one side or two side lighting next we
change the function name here create a
surface with color map so we change
create a map
and then either color data it says input
argument here we have normal data we
need
the color that
this character time means column update
here we need to remove this color
and add a new default value
for the is to sign right here here we
set the default value one it means the
true side like if zero is one side here
we create a request buffer normal buffer
we also need to create the calibre here
color
and use a color data
next here is the buffer the re the first
wordpress buffer this normal buffer we
also need to add
another buffer for the color map data so
here we need to set the scene location
to 2
we don't need to change the other part
of the code for the pipeline so other
part is the same as that used in the
last project the code for the uniform
data camera and a uniform barf layout is
the same i said used in the last
project so we don't need to change
anything here but here the lighter
parameter we need to make some changes
because the light color we already
removed so we remove this light color
but we need to add another parameter is
called is two side lighting parameter so
we need to add a parameter here
the person is two side lighting
parameter but a zero zero but we will
make the parameter consisting is a
vector4 array the other thing we need to
make a change is that we should either
the color buffer to the render path we
have workers buffer on a normal buffer
we also need to add color bar for here
this is called the color
color for pex slot 2. okay we finished
the modification to this file right now
so we can see
this file next we need to make some
modification to the cdl code because we
want to incorporate lighting and color
map into the seeder so now from src
folder open the
cdr.wtxl file from this open this file
and we need to replace its content with
new code
this seeder is very similar to that used
in the last project inside a vertex
cedar in addition to the rotate position
you can see on the normal vector we also
add the color at location 2
to this input
within the vs main function we process
the color map and assign this karma to
the vehicle in the fragment seeder here
we use the process column update as our
object primary color here you can see we
color is processed from
graphics cedar we use it as a primary
color to get the final color inside the
fragrance theater the main function you
can see
here there is two side lighting
parameter clearly called the primary
zero control whether the lighting is
applied to my side of two sides
of our surface we're setting it to one
for two side lighting which is also
default setting for two side lighting
you can see this for one side for front
side we diffuse we use n dot l spectral
light we use n dot edge
if two side lighting we add another term
here for the diffuse we use minus a dot
l for the spectral we use a minus a a
dot edge this means for the backside
light we just reverse the normal vector
to get the light for the back side now
we can save this file
okay now we finish the programming for
color map in this project
in the last project we discussed the
color map model in this project i will
explain how to use this model to build
simple 3d surfaces here is an example of
3d simple surface created using a peaks
function
mathematically a surface draws away a
function on a surface for each x and z
coordinates in a region of interest for
each x and z
value pair the simple 3d surface can
have at most when wave value we can
define a simple surface by the way
coordinates of a point about a
rectangular grid in the x z plane the
surface is formed by a joint adjacent
point using straight lines typically the
surfaces formed using rectangular mass
grids however web gpu only provides
triangles as the basic units to
represent any surface in 3d in order to
represent a surface using traditional
quadrilaterals we need to write our win
functions you can download the source
code used in this project from this
github repository link this specific
commit version is used for this project
now start visual studio code and open
project 8 that will build in the last
section
here shows the code used in the project
8. first we need to add a new typescript
file called
surfacedata.ts to the src folder src
folder add a new file called surface
ts
we needed to introduce wagner 3 input
like 3 from gm matrix library
and also needed to import
from columnar data wts file introduce
add colors function first let's
add a utility function called a
normalized point that will be used to
normalize the point to the range of
minus one and a one so we need to add a
function
normalized function you can see here
this function take a 3d vector3 here the
points x data range x minima x minimum
where minimum y maximum z minima and z
maximum and also introduce a global
scale a parameter that allows you to
change the value range for the x y and z
coordinates this will be convenient for
setting the default size of our surface
this function returns the normalized 3d
point for our simple 3d surface i saw in
here this surface can be formed by
quadrilateral mass grid here is the one
of the quadrilateral this kind of
showing here is a unit grid cell this
unit grid is quadrature with four
vertices p0 p1 p2 and p3 we can divide
this calculator into two triangles p0 p1
p2 this one triangle another triangle is
p2 p3 and p0 as shown here we will
create a vertex data normal vector data
and current map data for this quadro
letter now we can add a new function
called create a code
you can see here that this function
takes four points just as soon here
point zero one two and three take this
four point as is the inputs arguments it
also takes a way data range where
minimum y maxima as well as the karma
name is the input parameters because we
want to add column f to the where values
for our surface of course you can karmap
the data value in the other direction
such as x and z direction but we usually
add a comment to the
values here we first create a vertex
position data for the six vertices this
point zero point one point two is the
first triangle this is a segment
triangle point two 0.3 and 0.0 so this
is the vertex for this unit cell for
these two triangles
next we define the normal vector for
this quadrature we already discussed how
to obtain the normal vector for this
quadrature in the previous project it is
simply equal to the cross product of
these two diagonal lines of this
quadrature here we instant use these two
lines first is p2 p0 p2 p0 we called ca
another line p3 and p1 p3 p1 we called
the db now we get the cross product we
call cp these two line then we normalize
these cp cross products we get the
normal vector for this quadrilateral so
all the vector x's on this quadrature
have the same normal vectors
next we add the column of data two
vertices for this quadrature you can see
the p0 p1 p2 and p3 this is the column
of data for these four
vertices for p0 you can see we add the
karma data to it by calling add colors
function with a square component p01 and
use the y data range where minimum and
maximum the add colors function was
implemented in the last project if you
want to add climate data to the other
direction for example the x direction
you should use x the data range and also
p0 here inside of row b0 this x
component similarly we add the column
map data to the other three vertices
finally we add this karma app data to
these two triangles this is 506 vertices
they have different color match on
different vertices finally create a core
function returns a vertex normal and a
color for this unit grid
this create call function here only
creates the data for single unit grid
now we need to create a data for the
entire surface
we need to add a new function called
simple surface data
this is a function create data for the
entire surface this function takes f
here this input argument f is a mass
function that describes the 3d simple
surface we designed to define the data
range in the x z plane using minima and
maximum value for the x and z next to
input parameters a x and n z represent
the greater divisions along the x and z
directions here the scale is a global
scaling parameter used in the normalized
point a function the scale way a
parameter is used to control the wave
value height relative to the x and z
value that is the wave parameter here
controls aspect ratio of our surface
plot
inside this method we first define the
size of unit grid you can see dx and dz
we then calculated the vertex position
on our surface by calling the function f
you can see use this for loop inside
that we called f x z a function this
will describe our surface here we also
calculate value range where minimum y
where maxima y next we reset where
value range use a scale way a parameter
here next we normalize a vertex position
by calling the normalized point using
the value ring for x y and z and also
the scale inside this double for loop we
first define the unit cell p0 p1 p2 and
p3 is a unit cell and then called the
create a call function to get the vertex
position normal vector and column map
data for this unit grid so this vertex
normal and then color for our surface
finally this
simple surface data function returns the
vertex data
normal data and column map data now we
finish the programming for 3d simple
surfaces in this project in next project
we will use this framework to create a
3d sync surface
with both the lighting effect and color
map
in last two projects we discussed the
color map model and a simple 3d surface
construction in this project i will
explain how to use the color map model
and the simple surface data function to
create a 3d sync surface as shown here
this pretty sync surface we wanted to
create in this project you can download
the source code used in this project
from this github repository link this
specific commit version is used for this
project
now start with visual studio code and
open our project line that will build in
the last section
here is the code used in the last
project
first we need to make some changes to
the
index.html file from the dist folder
open
index.html file here we need to change
this h1 title to sing
surface
and design we need to
change the parameter here
you can see here we have a two side
light a parameter lighter controls
whether we want to apply the lighting
effect to one side or two side of the
surface here is a drop down menu for the
color map that contains 11 karmab names
we defined in the karmap data.ts file so
you can select different color map for
our surface from this dropdown here is
the scale parameter
that let you set the default size and
expect the ratio for the sync surface
now we can save this file
now let's define our sync function add a
new text script file called mass func
dot test file to the src folder xrc
folder add a new file called mess
font.ts file
here is the definition of the single
function here are defined as square root
of x squared plus z squared this
function equals to sine r or if are not
equal to zero otherwise if it is equal
to zero this function equal to one uh in
fact this function is a fourier
transform of the rectangular function
now we add some code here to define this
function
and you can see this function is very
simple it takes x and z and a center
parameter here i say say input arguments
the center parameter here lets you set
the location of our single surface
inside this function we define r use
this formula as shown here so here let
of r equal to 0 this function equal to
y otherwise equal to sine r over r this
function returns a vector three point on
the single surface here
now we can see this file and close it
next we need to make some changes to the
main.js file from src folder
openmint.ts file and now we need to
replace the code with the new
code his muscle code for render pipeline
and rhinopath have been already included
in the surface.ts file so the main.ts
file here becomes very simple here we
first reading something use the simple
surface data from surface data.tl file
and design we introduce the sync
function from
mathfunc.ts file next from
surface dot tx file we introduce creator
surface with the column map and also
introduce a light input
interface from this surface.ts file next
we create a new function
called create a surface this function
takes
life inputs is animation and a karma
name and a scale and a scale way as is
input arguments
inside this function we call the simple
surface data with you see here the sync
function as the input argument from this
simple surface data method we can get
the vertex position
a normal vector and current map data we
design called create a surface with the
karma f a function to create our single
surface with a lighting and color map
effects and here we define the default
input parameters and design we call
create surface a function to create a 3d
sync surface
the default
lighting and color map effect
this part of the code allows the user to
recreate the sync surface with different
input parameters here this could allow
the user to select the different color
map from this drop-down menu now we
finished the modification to the min.ks
file we can save this file
now we can run the following command in
the terminal window to bundle our tab
script code open the terminal window and
run the command in p.m wrong parallel
to bond our attack script code
in production mode
okay the pan file is created
successfully now we can click this go
live link to open cron canary to view
our sync service click this link
okay here is our single surface with the
default two side lighting and a jet
color map displayed on this page
now let's check what happens if we use
one side lighting so we use a camera
control this one side we set it to zero
you see you see the back there's no
diffusion and a specular light in on the
back but only has a very weak ambient
light here if we set it to one back
you can see the back
the difference the one side and the two
side you have a light on the back here
the scale set the default size or a
surface for example we change it to one
you get a smaller surface here send it
to three
you will get big surface so they can
control the default size of the surface
go back to two and here the scale way
let you control the aspect ratio for
example we set it to zero you get a
taller the surface and change it to the
0.5
you get a solder and a fatter surface so
we change it to 0.3 so you can use this
parameter to control the aspect ratio
next we can change the color map from
this drop-down menu for example item
[Music]
bom
cool
cooper
gray
hot
hsv
spring
summer
and winter
so you can get a different
color map
for our surface
you can see that in web gpu we can
easily create a beautiful 3d surface
with lighting and color map effect you
can create your wind surface by simply
providing your wing mesh functions
so now we complete our project team
you can use web gpu to create advanced
graphics in your web applications here
are some more examples from my recently
published book practical web gpu
graphics here are some of parametric 3d
surface examples they all looks
beautiful because they have both color
map and lighting effects as we did for
the
simple 3d sync surface in our projects
here are text map examples on 3d objects
texture plays an important role in 3d
graphics the modern gpus have support
for imaging texture built-in on the
hardware level texture mapping on 3d
object provides a more interesting and
realistic look
these examples demonstrate that you can
do texture mapping on sphere cylinder on
a 3d surface you can also use multiple
textures on 3d object you can see here
each face of our 3dq has a different
image texture here are examples of
domain coloring for functions with
complex variables
these beautiful pictures are drawn pixel
by pixel based on bitmap renderer with a
computation intensive process here we
perform all
calculations on a random directly in gpu
which makes possible for our real time
animation here this is impossible in cpu
these are 3d fractal examples we provide
more structures than 2d factors again
these nice pictures can be only created
in gpu
in cpu
it is too slow
and impossible to have this real-time
animation
are some examples for large particle
systems this is a computer voice and we
try to simulate the floating behavioral
balls this picture shows particle
kinematics with correlation to the wall
this shows three mass centers that
attract particles here we use compute
cedar to perform
physics-related computations
and update the positions and velocities
on each frame this is only possible in
gpu for simulating this large particle
system in real time if you want to learn
how to create these pictures and
particle systems please visit my website
at
douglassew.net.com and my youtube
channel i had a practical programming
with adasu
thank you for watching